it really is like a writing desk and
just a nice accessory to the master
almost seems like a secretary set up to
write down all the information before
you go in the room and have sex if I go
by two chains two chains I'm over the
top sometimes and right now we're going
to check out most expensive big [ __ ]
it's definitely crazy
what about what up is two chains today
I'm most expensive [ __ ] the jewel
penthouse New York Palace I mean it
comes with the Maybach above the hookers
check it out
David Chase from a manager here at
Bally's she was going on I want to show
you the jewels we heard a lot about the
Joseph with three bedrooms six bathrooms
lots of incredible space to hang out and
party in and be romantic we partnered
with a guy named market Katz is a
Beverly Hills jeweler he actually keeps
a few million dollars of his jewelry
here in the suite which is kind of
creates real stuff big stuff this
cascading chandelier we call the
waterfall of diamonds all over the place
20-something look at the tape measure
out Utah we call this main space the
grand parlor because it's so grand
18-foot windows luckily we've got a day
that's not too hazy outside this week is
really comfortable for obviously hanging
out do it TV or whatever so I can throw
a party you know you can throw a party
just gotta be careful the carpet what's
the night in this room gonna cost me
well we're friends now so you get a
discount but anybody else that calls me
it's $25,000 in them damn you know
here's the thing you got people will
come for a few nights the comforter a
week or 10 days and then truth is off
people who will rent it month at a time
25,000 of the night you're doing the
math on your three night stay I'm Nigel
bear to stay three night when you commit
to a several months day we're gonna do
the suite for 250 Tudor 2000 month now
compared to that twenty five thousand is
it down at the downright bargain it's a
bargain here's what I've learned in this
business
everything is relative so tell me what
comes for 250 a month you've got
dedicated concierge dedicated staff in
the private lobby downstairs
you got butler service you've got room
service of course those are a
full-service hotel 24 hour room sir
for the food sir oh you got a paper
booth all right you know that's how we
that's the extra any kind of food and
beverage event service stuff it's all
in-house so we can make all that happen
but yeah you're paying for it as you as
you use it our house car which is a
mailbox they can run you around town
nearby or whatever you bring you around
town well you couldn't want to leave
you're gonna pay to stay here I like to
go to Harlem and eat you can take me to
Harlem for you cuz you're in this week
yeah what kind of people what kind of
clientele that you have is this place
like vacant have the time or do you have
people that constantly want to spend
twenty five thousand a night truth is it
is probably vacant half the time cuz I
probably booked it about half or a
little less at a time sometimes
celebrities sometimes royalty we
actually do a lot of Saudi and royalty
Prince princess business and then just
business matter business women who you
know know our hotel know these big
Suites and that's just their choice to
use these these large spaces we're
taking the grand staircase up to the
second floor this is the master bedroom
this little room outside of the master
it's set up almost to do private jewelry
showings here within the suite it really
is like a writing desk and just a nice
accessory to the master room with 25,000
it should come with a massage is she
coming hooker
we don't offer all those services but we
have a spa I thought we throw in a
massage this is the master suite which
is the master bathroom
I can't last spend a lot of time in the
bathroom too
you
we've seen parties in here of 60 people
it's just party and going on every
alcohol is loud music is occasional hits
Oh marijuana smell luckily there's a
terrace so people can smoke outside guys
I want to look at to get to the third
floor Paris the only way to get up there
is to actually take the private elevator
this is a solarium the indoor space
exclusively to the jewel suite man let
me say it right I want to see it
properly this is the solarium little
area cuz I'm a rapper I need the data to
put these words in where they fit in the
solarium you know I'm saying eat celery
a lot of it I guess to take this
treatment a lot of time up here working
fireplace wood-burning fireplace New
York City on the roof of my building all
of this is support oh that's where we
were it's hard to believe there's still
more I said you got a Ferrari boots and
things like that I wish I could tell you
there's a Ferrari included still just to
make Aurora doesn't let me drive a
Ferrari to Harlem Success Park hot tub
so you can imagine how the party you
know he's end up up here I'm so happy to
be here and that's your neighbors and
the champagne suite careful case
anybody's naked over there this is
something I would like to experience at
least one time in my life I got to admit
that I'm from Atlanta Georgia won't have
anything like this in the lamps I would
love to use this for the view for a
party I think I want to do my listening
party here man 25,000 a night bringing
some hookers what's not here what you
set up in here because we got the New
York City the relationships I mean
anything's possible
they down the street we put it in your
family now so we're gonna be able to
find the time to have you check this out
stuff like that right yeah y'all heard
um we got an on camera no listen I'm
committed now twenty-five thousand two
hundred and fifty thousand a month the
rings in there you can't have [ __ ] on
the wall you can't have is it [ __ ]
worth it you tell me leave a comment
subscribe to the GQ chump for more most
expensively [ __ ]